Reino Unido y la mancomunidad de
Naciones tienen un nuevo reinado con una
multitud estremecida en las lluviosas
calles de Londres Carlos y Camila
salieron desde el Palacio de buckingham
a bordo del Diamond jubile State coach
un carruaje cerrado y moderno que fue
fabricado para el cumpleaños número 80
de la Reina Isabel II a su llegada a la
abadía de Westminster a los nuevos Reyes
les esperaba una ceremonia llena de
religión simbolismo y más de 2000
invitados el soberano de 74 años Recibió
la corona de San Eduardo utilizada desde
1661 por el Rey Carlos II un ejemplar
que pesa unos 2.2 kilos Y está formado
por un marco de oro e incrustaciones
como rubíes y granates también recibió
Cuatro espadas un cetro un orbe y dos
brazaletes uno que representa la
sinceridad y otro que simboliza la
sabiduría para posteriormente jurar a su
pueblo
el juramento de coronación se ha
mantenido durante siglos y está
consagrado en la ley está dispuesto a
hacer el juramento
después de Carlos III Camila Parker
balls fue coronada como reina en una
ceremonia diseñada para ser más corta y
con menos pompa que las anteriores
rodeados de otros miembros de la familia
real y bajo la entonación del himno
nacional Carlos III y Camila se
retiraron de la abadía de Westminster en
el Gold que tiene más de 260 años y se
ha utilizado en todas las coronaciones
desde la de Guillermo IV en 1831 el
destino el balcón del Palacio de
buckingham desde donde la familia real
saludó al pueblo en medio de largas
ovaciones cerrando la ceremonia de
coronación una tradición de más de mil
años y que confirma el derecho de Carlos
III y Camila a reinar